[Musique]
alors hier les bleus ont battu andorre 3
0 c'est peut-être un bon début pour se
qualifier pour la coupe 2020 meyer ont
regardé beaucoup plus les tribunes que
le terrain bienvenue jean leonetti
garçons jour président de l air
actuellement et en même temps médecins
ça va nous servir tout à l'heure mais
noël le graet il a déclenché un
tohu-bohu général en demandant aux
arbitres de ligue 1 et ligue 2 de ne
plus arrêter systématiquement les matchs
dans l'est dans le cas de chants injures
banderole homophobe l'homophobie dans
l'es7 c'est une affaire d'état qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est plus qu'une erreur
est-il acceptable de dire on peut
arrêter quand il des propos racistes et
on peut pas on peut continuer quand ils
les propos homophobes
c'est la même violence c'est la même
haine que ça déclenche donc
effectivement je pense qu'il va se
rendre compte que qui l'a dit une bêtise
il va revenir sur ses paroles on peut
pas accepter que dans l'enceinte du
football y est d'aider situation dans
laquelle cette violence verbale qui
entraîne une violence physique c'est pas
par hasard à monsieur kabbaj queue à la
sortie des matchs de foot on est obligé
de mettre des crs c'est pas normal que
ce sport qui est le plus beau
à mes yeux est le plus populaire soit
entachée toujours d'insultés de
violences
donc je pense qu'il faut une réflexion
globale même je le regrette
il faut qu'il revienne à la raison et
qui m'a mais la nuance est déjà son
propos là il faut pas lyon il ya le
racisme on arrête tout il dit aux
arbitres mais dans le cas d'un match
mais ce ne peut pas être système être
dans les heures sombres de notre pays
les régimes nazis en ont persécuté à la
fois les juifs et et les
les homosexuels c'est pas par hasard que
que on associe cette haine de l'autre
cette haine de la différence donc je
pense que il faut qu'on connaît une
attitude qui soit à la fois très
rigoureuse mais ouvrons un petit peu le
champ et se pose en nous la question
pourquoi le football entre haine de la
violence pourquoi on insulte un arbitre
pourquoi les joueurs insultent leurs
singles une réponse aux questions que
vous posez vos mains vous et moi je
jouais au football je veux au rugby et
quand je sors d'un match de rugby j'ai
pas la même ambiance rivaux des de
violence et de s gens là aiment tout le
monde voulait donc du pays qui s'exprime
et c'est peut-être surprenant de voir
que le sport prend cette dimension est
en danger de la société dangereux qu'un
sport populaire véhicule la haine mais
est ce que vous mettez une hiérarchie
vous distribution n'y a pas d'heure
shinra discrimination voilà la france
est un pays démocratique et humaniste ça
va et à faire des tâches du tout à leur
président de la république s'en mêle il
est intervenu hier veut pas dire qu'ils
ajoutent de la clarté à ce débat mais
l'aide intervenu écoutons le football
devra consigner tout le monde et je
pense que quand le football réconcilier
tout le monde il doit apporter aussi les
valeurs de concorde de notre pays a pas
de polémique à avoir sur ces sujets faut
il faut dire
avoir une clarté sur les principes et du
discernement dans l'application à
l'arrêt donc je souhaite que tout le
monde travaille ensemble il faut pas
créer de fausses polémiques
je suis moi-même amateurs de football je
ne suis pas non plus naïfs et on sait ce
qu'est un stade qui s'embrase et parfois
les noms d'oiseaux pour dire le moins
qui vole donc je suis pas en train de
dire que tout ça doit se terminer mais
on peut pas expliquer tous les jours à
nos jeunes et moins jeunes qu'il faut
mettre de la décence dans le pays qui
font enlever de la violence et dire il
faut accepter toute éternité les pires
choses
chacun doit pas bouger là vous êtes
pratiquement d'accord
et puis oui c'est j'aurais aimé un peu
plus de clarté c'est un peu dur en même
temps la ministre des sports qui fait un
peu la tête
monsieur le graet et le grade se sont
vus hier lors du match et ils vont se
retrouver probablement j'avais moi même
temps les supporters et ils idée aussi
de de noël le graet
il voudrait que soit organisé un match
de foot france algérie et bientôt
l'année prochaine et les algériens sont
ravis ils sont demandeurs le président
de la république est paraît-il favorable
et vous qu'est ce que vous dites dans ce
cas-là algérie est un pays qui joue au
football qui joue plutôt bien on a des
joueurs d'ailleurs en commun qui sont
franco algérien donc c'est une très
bonne idée mais est ce que c'est ce
qu'on accepterait aujourd'hui qu'on
siffle l'hymne national au début de ce
match
donc est-ce qu'on arrêtera le match si
il y à des sifflets sur le hic certes il
ya des risques mais il y aura de la
formation de partage autres pour un
match qui aura lieu à angers ça votre
est peut-être le record atteint biais
qu'il faut un petit peu de fraternité 1
et est aussi de rigueur dans notre
république c'est sur une leçon de sport
de politique et d'histoire les urgences
vous connaissez ces sujets dans la
longue crise d urgence est ce que votre
droite fait ce matin à travers bois mea
culpa
non je pense pas parce que en 2009 on
fait une loi qui s'appelle hôpital
patients santé territoires et qui met
tous les ingrédients pour régler les
problèmes des urgences après il ya des
réticences il ya des blocages
enfin à l'hôpital d'antibes il ya les
systèmes qui ont été mises en place par
exemple il ya une maison de santé qui
permet d'absorber la bobologie d'aidé
urgence qui sont pas très graves avec
des médecins libéraux
il ya une hospitalisation pour pas faire
attendre les gens devant les brawn ont
serré les mains pures droit j'avais bien
sympa vous perturber javi rhône est pour
rien jamais perdre à une crise
clermontois mais est ce que vous
comprenez qu'il ya un durcissement
aujourd'hui des grèves
le manager jef gavage c'est pas un
problème d'argent
le l'erreur majeure du gouvernement
c'est d'avoir dit on va vous donner 100
euros de plus par mois c'est pas un
problème uniquement 300 c'est un
problème d'organisation
c'est le seul pays la france dans lequel
vous avez les gens qui ont mal aux dents
qui arrive avec les traumatiser de la
route est bien très bien mais ça fait
partie des revendications des
urgentistes la moitié de démesure gentis
du pays et qui recrutent des
augmentations de salaires 300 euros vous
dites centre et à 300 euros gerrican dès
l'ouverture des lits et qui demandent en
même temps des milliers de postes mais
agnès buzyn a donné sous la pression de
six mois de grève
754 millions sur trois ans ir stanislas
guérini désirez plus d'un milliard mais
pourquoi c'est jamais assez
jamais assez parce que quand vous avez
un système qui dysfonctionne vous pouvez
rajouter de l'argent
vous avez toujours des gens qui sont
dans une situation d'épuisement avec la
violence que comporte aujourd'hui les
urgences avec des brancards dans les
couloirs avec une situation dans
laquelle réfléchit c'est une seconde
ces gens ne se battent pas au coach des
gones sont uniquement pinon uniquement
pour de l'argent ou pour des
améliorations
ils se battent pour bien faire leur
métier c'est pour ça que d'emblée on a
alerté le gouvernement précédent qui n'a
rien fait maintenant thorel n'a rien
fait on a alerté le gouvernement dès
qu'il a été mis en place
personnellement je les fais au premier
ministre qui était conscient qu'il y
avait un problème donc vous comprenez ce
qui est en train de se passer
les grèves le durcissement des grèves
mais bien sûr réseau je les comprends
d'autant plus que la grève aux urgences
ou mettez un brassard en grève et vous
travaillez et vous continuez à soigner
les gens les urgentistes manifestent
aujourd'hui pas loin de la cgt de
philippe martinez vous défie le riz avec
eux quoi écoutez moi j'ai jamais défilé
parce que je pense que dans la position
d'un homme politique et il doit surtout
se battre au niveau des idées au niveau
de l'assemblée nationale et dans un
cadre plus démocratique que les
manifestations mais pour autant et
j'approuve cette situation et j'approuve
situation attention on est dans une
situation qui n'est que la partie
immergée de l'iceberg
c'est l'ensemble de l'organisation pour
réorganiser refonder le système de santé
et il faut faire appel aux médecins de
ville qu'ils aient un rôle un peu plus
là aussi actifs reliés en l'air j'ai
regardé comme membres et en particulier
dans le gouvernement précédent de madame
touraine on a clivé on a dit à la
médecine privée et puis à la médecine
publique donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui on réconcilie
c'est de médecine et on les fait
travailler ensemble parce que le malade
ça lui est égal d'être soigné par un
médecin libéral ou par un médecin
hospitalier qui veut être soigné on
oublie pas et on le répète qu' à la
moitié des urgences
ce qu'ils sont en grève une autre moitié
qui même si elles souffrent etc
elle fait face et elle répond aux
besoins des patients mais derrière le
malaise réel on réponde partout au
besoin derrière le manège rennes et ce
n'est pas une opération politique
ah non alors alors franchement seul e si
vous discutez avec des hospitaliers
certains certains sont de gauche de
droite c'est intéressant pour le
gouvernement ou contre mais ils sont
dans une situation d'impasse
imaginez quelques ravages que vous soyez
en train de faire votre travail et que
vous puissiez pas le faire que vous
soyez en responsabilité que vous vous
dites je suis sur la corde raide du
matin au soir personnel infirmier mettez
votre blouse blanche et lé défilé cet
après midi aux est apparemment de tout
coeur avec eux darwish d'accord avec
vous parce que j'étais facile tout coeur
avec eux mais on ne défile pas j'ai vécu
avec eux très bien l'europe
vous avez été ministre des affaires
européennes et vous étiez hier si j'ai
vu à à bruxelles our souls à von der
leyen nouveau président de la commission
nouvelle a présenté les 27 commissaires
de bruxelles 13 femmes sur 27 est ce que
ça fait une équipe solide moderne agile
avec de l'autorité je pense que d'abord
la prise sur elle et elle est de grande
qualité
un du m18 ablement et les francophones
et les francophiles
au passage elle fait partie du parti
populaire européen dans lequel les
républicains adhèrent et là une vision
qui à mon avis est une vision positive
parce qu'elle parle enfin de deux choses
qui nous préoccupe le contrôle de
l'immigration et la taxe carbone aux
frontières parle aussi du numérique elle
parle de cybersécurité est justement
très bien là avec elle deux
vice-présidents champions franck
timmerman c'est madame margrethe verges
de ryan que les téléspectateurs de ces
news connaissent puisque elle a été
interrogée ici et sylvie dillard va
avoir le portefeuille immense de
l'industrie du marché intérieur de la
défense de l'espace de la cybersécurité
vous estimez que la france est bien
traité
la france est traitée normalement
et sylvie goulard c'est une femme qui
connaît bien les procédures européennes
donc marrant il raison de la choisir le
seul problème c'est que pourquoi les
sorties du gouvernement si elle est
sortie de gouvernement et spontanément
c'est elle qui a décidé de partir parce
que il y avait une suspicion sur sa
personne
est-ce que la suspicion a disparu et est
ce que on peut ne pas être ministre
français et être commissaire européen
donc il ya quand même une interrogation
cl ça veut dire est ce que vous êtes en
train de lire ce matin je suis en train
de dire que l'ensemble des modem sylvie
goulard mais françois bayroux sont
sortis du gouvernement pour une raison
qui était qu'il y avait une suspicion
sur leur attaché parlementaire qui
n'avait pas été qui avait quitté des
emplois fictifs
cette suspicion a entraîné la démission
si la démission à exister au niveau du
ministère
pourquoi en sommes quelques uns à la
commission elle pas la nommer je pense
que dans les jours qui viennent
françois bayrou va être rappelé au
gouvernement vous lui direz pas deux
poids deux mesures je trouve que c'est
curieux mais qu'on dise vous ne pouvez
pas être ministre français mais vous
pouvez être commissaire européen vous
anticipez françois bégaudeau
gouvernement non je serai ses boutades
moutame avec un sens politique mais
subit goulard sera devant le parlement
européen
moi hier j'étais à naucelle et je vous
je vous garantis qu'il ya un malaise sur
l'ensemble des acteurs européens en se
disant tiens quelque est drôle
d'attitude de la france qui ne peut pas
nommer quelqu'un au ministère mais qui
peut la déléguée à l'europe
quand vous l'attaquez est ce qu'en fait
vous visez pas emmanuel macron la faute
et l'état emmanuel macron les pintes
sirigu la tvq la rade a eu le courage de
démissionner sur un élément de suspicion
alors elle va passer
elle va être auditionné deux par le
parlement européen est ce que les huit
eurodéputés de votre couleur vont
essayer si c'est possible de lui faire
la vie dure
bah il va pas lui faire la vie dure
quand même on va demander quelques
clarifications et quelques explications
c'est à dire on va demander au nord dé
de cette procédure
ça vous regarde pas il ya une
une enquête de justice elle est présumée
innocente alors pourquoi démissionner
pourquoi démissionner quand ça commence
bien
elle arrive elle arrive déjà avec des
patients la loi bioéthique la gpa la
gestation pour autrui ne figurera pas
dans le débat
peut-être dans le débat oui mais pas
dans la loi il y à une circulaire qui
autoriserait finalement le gouvernement
a autorisé la filiation des enfants nés
d'une gpa né à l'étranger quelle est
votre position là-dessus et il tend bien
évident que la france pouvait
apparemment pas faire autrement puisque
depuis cinq ans elle était critique est
attaqué par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme mais la circulaire
taubira puis la décision de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme fait
que en fait on condamne les mères
porteuses mais on valide la conséquence
des mères porteuses
au nom de quelque chose qui est
humainement compréhensible c'est
l'enfant doit pas subir de complète
conséquences mais je le dis depuis le
début et je suis pas le seul à le dire
la pma la procréation médicalement
assistée pour tout aboutira à la
gestation pour autrui à dire aux mères
porteuses si vous aviez écouté east and
is l'aciérie numéro un du parti
en marche étiez proche voisine la
république il a dit hier absolument pas
la gpa restera hors la loi est un
interdit absolu réécouter leur écoute ne
s'agit pas d'ouvrir la gpa en france il
s'agit simplement il mettre fin à cette
situation hypocrite et douloureuse dans
lequel vivaient de fait un certain
nombre d'enfants mais nous avons
toujours dit aux gars je vous répond
très clairement nous avons dit que cette
ligne rouge de la gpa ne souhaitons pas
la franchir nous sommes défavorables à
la marchandisation du corps humain j'ai
le gabas et que les lignes rouges à le
change est le change d'endroit
écoutez ce qu'a dit le premier ministre
quand il n'était pas encore premier
ministre il a dit on ne fera pas la pma
parce que la pma entraînera la gpa
premiers ministres edouard philippe
prenne aussi deviennent les garanties
d'un garnement
et maintenant on nous explique ne vous
inquiétez pas on fera la paix main mais
il y aura pas la gpa et les eaux grasses
âge quand on nous a expliqué que la pma
il y avait aucun
blême sur la filiation et que maintenant
on est obligé de dire il ya maires et
maires dans un état civil il ya deux
mers et on nous explique en plus qu'il
ya une semaine
le maire prédominante celle qui aurait
accouché franchement mettre un débat
même quelques temps qui va être serré
mais qui montre et vous aussi à les
démasquer les républicains à l'heure
mais c'est pas des divisions sur le
cabba ont manifesté comme françois
bellamy d'autres règles aménager des
tournois à une période sur la fin de vie
il y avait dans mon groupe parlementaire
des gens qui étaient pour l'euthanasie
et pour la légalisation pure nazis on
leur a donné la parole sur ces sujets là
qui est la liberté de penser ça me
paraît être la moindre des choses quand
il a raté la liberté chérie au genou on
n'exclut pas les gens parce qu'ils ne
pensent pas comme nous liberté de vote
la sécurité sociale est ce qu elle doit
ou non remboursés la pma cet homme c'est
un problème annexe mais ça pose leur
hystérie non non c'est pas oui non c'est
le fait de dire est ce que la médecine
elle doit uniquement s'occuper des
pathologies ou est ce qu'elle doit
répondre aux désirs diallo s'occupe des
pathologies c'est déjà un poids
financier si elle s'occupe de tous les
désirs
on va aller dans un même infinie un pato
palabres politique mais les sujets qui
sont dans la société aujourd'hui la
publication du livre de tariq ramadan a
été autorisé par la justice la liberté
d'expression à a prévalu qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensez vous que je le lirai
pas parce que je veux dire cet homme est
un manipulateur
il a prétendu défendre un islam intégré
en fait ils déforment l'islam intégriste
donc sous des couverts de de séduction
et de paroles douces y ait en fait c'est
un homme qui est homophobe tiens au
passage et qui considère la femme comme
comme inférieures donc il n'est pas dans
les valeurs de la république
dès maintenant il se compare à dreyfus
donc il ya un moment où la victimisation
des coupables me paraît être excessive
aux pensées qui va faire peut-être
campagne pour se présenter comme une
victime des biens sur des barea qui peut
avoir à nouveau de l'influenza les
banlieues j'espère qu'ils ingèrent
l'europe ait dans les banlieues ils
comprendront que cet homme était un
manipulateur
vous avez parlé de la comparaison qui
l'a fait avec
réfuge dans l'émission de dimanche qui
s'appelle sans détour jean michel
blanquer
il avait stigmatisé lui même on leur
écoute il ya de l'indécence dans ce
propos c'est évident dire cela c'est
vraiment c'est comparer c'est comparer
al capone à nelson mandela si vous
voulez donc monsieur ramadan et à l'état
dreyfus que al capone est à nelson
mandela donc je pense que biya le choix
de l'indécence parfois par certaines
personnes qui pensent que la meilleure
défense c'est l'attaqué
quelques jours le prochain président et
l'air va être élu est-ce qu'il doit
avoir la vocation et la mission d'être
candidat à l'elysée en 2022 alors on a
mis ça comme principe là pour apaiser en
partie qui est effectivement en
difficulté on leur construit on a une
défaite électorale donc il y en a dix
comme principes et les trois candidats
sont d'accord ils seront pas candidats
donc ma position jacob probablement
futur président devra celui qui sont
élus et le parti etc
mais comment vous choisirez celui qui
sera le candidat ou celle qui sera le
candidat investi là aussi réfléchissons
ensemble non avant l'élection de
françois hollande
il est à 2 % dans les sondages non avant
l'élection d' emmanuel macron il n'est
même pas connu du grand public donc
trois ans avant dire qui va être notre
candidat
ça me paraît très très prématuré donc
vous savez qu'il peut émerger surgir
vous n'avez même pas mais c'est dur
d'aller dans la bataille politique sans
savoir avec qui et quel programme et
c'est ma bataille politique ses débuts
nicipal à la prochaine et la prochaine
bataille politique nous nous sommes
implantés nous nous avons des maires ils
ont qui vous allez présenter à paris et
nous nous avons vous allez présenter
appellera le meilleur vous avez du
retard
est ce que le meilleur avec nadir kg
offrait à marquer que en marche à un peu
d'avancé puisqu'il a déjà deux candidats
ouais donc de temps en temps il vaut
mieux être en retard ma dernière
remarque est ce que la meilleure le
meilleur argument contre emmanuel bacon
qui a recommencé à faire un petit grand
débat hier à bonneuil pour parler de la
pauvreté
est ce que le meilleur argument c'est de
l'accusé 2ce chirac tease et non moi
j'aime bien jacques chirac moi je trouve
qu'il a fait des choses sur le plan
international il a eu beaucoup de
courage et sur le plan intérieur il a
essayé de réparer les fractures qui sont
nombreuses à ce que le pays
les semelles en dise il s'offrit
chiraquie star il s'est alors dit c'est
à dire que maintenant il ya l'obstacle
et ils refusent l'obstacle et regardez
regardez sur les retraites on travaille
il travaille deux ans sur les retraites
avec monsieur de le voir et puis on dit
ça y est c'est près on a discuté avec
tout le monde et puis maintenant on dit
maintenant on va rediscuter
on va rediscuter parce que si ça peut
éviter des rébellions sociale c'est
l'ultime vient le mal à voir le nombre
sont jeunes et lutter réellement vous
pouvez c'est ma dernière remarque
l'accusé de d'immobilisme qu'en soi même
on est absent inaudible invisible
d'après vos militants l'ul comment je
pense que la laddh sanctions votre votre
avis est assez sévère si longtemps des
sympathisants et adhérents à leur nom je
pense que nous avons des sympathisants
et des adhérents on en a 130 milles et
yao come back partie canal quand on fait
des universités d'été les salles sont
presque vides
il a écouté on a fait des salles bien
plein pendant les européennes on a eu un
résultat qui était pas significatif
donc je préfère avoir des électeurs que
des militants merci d'être venus là là
le grenelle contre les violences
conjugales et familiales continue avec
toutes sortes de débats les hommes sont
en crise ils ne savent plus où ils sont
même dans le domaine le plus personnel
les plus intimes
demain je recevrais ivan jablonka qui
est un historien pour son livre des
hommes justes de nouvelles masculinité
et c'est un livre qui fait déjà beaucoup
de bruit
romain des arbres prend la suite la
halle g est l'avenir de l'homme
oui arak merci et bonne journée
à